Good morning and thank you for joining
us. Uh I'm joined by my colleagues Craig
Everett Oliger. Uh two experts in the
blockchain field. Um we had a few
technical issues this morning. So if you
feel like you're too stupid sometimes
because your computer doesn't work,
trust me, it happens to every single one
of us, including the two brightest
people I know in the space. So the
kickoff to today, we wanted to talk
about what is Bitcoin? What's what's so
important about it? Why is it relevant
to what we're doing? Um really it comes
down to this question though, what is
Bitcoin?
Why doesn't it work? And what's its true
value? So to kick that off, we thought
we'd pass the ball to uh Craig Everett
to talk about what was Bitcoin about and
what do we mean by real money. So over
to you Craig.
>> Um, thanks. The, uh, yeah, so real real
money, the phrase real money with a
capital R, capital M, kind of, uh, goes
back to
>> kind of TM at the end.
>> Um, yeah. So, I mean, that gets us into
uh, Minkin and and Hayek and and, um,
these folks that, uh, kind of informed
the Austrian school. The the whole point
of real money is is trying to point out
what's an underlying asset that we all
agree
uh is a tradable fungeable
asset of value that we can use as a mean
as a medium of exchange. Um there's a
progression from going from identifying
a thing that we all agree that we want
to trade to like every everything in the
world even like cow manure has an
economic use a function of some sort. So
there's an inherent value to it already.
When it comes to something like gold um
it has industrial uses scientific uses
and those have actually massively
increased in the last hundred years. Um,
but you know, gold being a universal,
one of the reasons it's universal is
that it can't be corrupted. So there's
only one way to create it, which is to
blow a star up. So you can't fake it.
It's easy to test. All the density tests
are very easy. The reactive tests are
very easy to do because gold does not
react. It's one of the only like purely
noble uh atomic structures. And you so
testing is very easy. You can't make you
can't just like pull extra of it out of
your ear and you can't fake it. Um, and
it's very easy to change forms. It's
soft and malleable and it doesn't it
doesn't get corrupted. It doesn't
corrode like silver. If you leave it
out, it'll tarnish. You start losing the
amount of silver that you have just
because it reacts. Um, so
that's interesting and that gives it
good industrial properties and certain
uses. But the uses of gold in industry
give it a certain utility value. But the
value that it holds as money
has completely surpassed what the
industrial value of gold is.
>> Arguably as you point out the industrial
utilization of gold is a relatively
recent thing. I mean if you go back to
the 18th 19th centuries its utilization
in industry was minimal. I mean for the
majority of human existence its use has
been as a form of the storage of wealth
the the means of paying for things.
>> Um you know people would foon their
wives and jewelry as a display of their
wealth their wife being [clears throat]
a cattle within that context. Obviously
that's something you wouldn't get away
with today but it is kind of
entertaining that it's considered a nice
thing for husbands to foon their wives
and jewelry still despite the advent of
feminism. But let's not stand stand on
that landmine. I appreciate that.
>> I was about to say, did you see the red
the red carpet walk the other day? Um,
>> no, I could I could appreciate that
there was a a a click sound as I stepped
on that particular one. [laughter]
>> So, I'm going to stay where I am and go
back to you and say, "Okay, so the point
you're making is that gold was this
medium of wealth transfer, expression,
storage, etc. it contained many of the
features of um that we would describe to
being a currency. Uh what then happened
is we began to store that gold within a
central bank. The central bank would
then issue notes that were promisory to
that storage. And the idea then was that
we would audit that amount of gold that
was in the in the storage. Uh at one
point the bank of England I think was
absolutely backed gold to pound and it
wasn't pegged. It was just a real
floating currency from the value of
gold. Yeah.
>> So when the Bank of England said uh I
shall promise that it promises to pay
the bearer the sum of they could quite
literally go into the vault and shave a
bit of gold off one of the vaults to
give it to them.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The banks were bearer bots.
>> Yeah. At that point and very interesting
testimony from JP Morgan to Congress. I
think it was 1912 where he was talking
at very different points about what
money really was and described the
greenback which is effectively what fiat
money is today as being not money um
that he described as being a credit
note. Of course the Daniel Greyber ideas
of the story of money um debt I think
it's debt the story of money for the
last 5,000 years again sits on this idea
that actually credit notes are what we
really trade in. But the more
fundamental point you make is that gold
is that thing. So linking that back to
Bitcoin, what is the what is the
association? Because I think the thing
that um there are many things that
people talk about in the context of
Bitcoin that people say are important
that this was the great breakthrough for
me and I think for us and if I'm
speaking out of tone, correct me. Um I
think the great innovation was that it
saw that as you point out gold can only
be created by blowing up a star. Uh this
is what this very small um volume of
finite material that can be easily
proven all of these features that this
could be done with a cryptographic
puzzle as well and the argument that
there must be a utility value is
actually undermined by the entire
history of gold as a base of value. So
sorry passing back to you guys.
>> No that's that's exactly correct.
Actually uh an interesting side note to
this people often ask um and I was asked
another at a previous conversation um
where did the central bank come up with
this idea of a target inflation rate of
2%. And the inflation rate of 2%
remember inflation originally meant
inflation of the core money supply. So
whatever your inzero number is,
>> it arguably still it is. It's just that
that's what it means to cure it. And
they're trying to redefine it in in this
in all sorts of wonderful ways. A little
bit like this. This is okay for me to
say because this is not going on YouTube
>> a bit like they defined an RNA adaptive
injection as a vaccine.
>> Yes. Yeah. They scrambled to rewrite
>> mine either. So straight off. No, but
they they scramble to rewrite the
dictionary and say no, this all the
stuff is vaccines. Now, in the same way,
the um as we now know the US aid funded
uh crazy media have also
often deliberately sometimes on accident
um conflated the meaning of price
increases and inflation price. So if you
inflate the money supply,
you are ostensibly
reducing you're diluting value. But
value of money is a common belief
complex. It's not just a strict one for
one. And markets are not purely
rational. We are agreeing that the
future value of money is likely impacted
by an inflation of the supply. That's
not always true. Um so that 2% inflation
rate where that target comes from is
that historically through feast, famine
and war humans have managed typically
and this is not perfectly smooth but
typically managed to increase the
available amount of gold in circulation
by 2% through mining historically. So
this idea of a 2% inflation rate often
it traces back to well we've typically
had gold stores go up by 2%.
Across most of Western society
throughout history so let's stick to
that since that's what we know and
they're trying to mimic that uh within
the fiat system. Now they have way
overblown that by quite a lot. In fact,
that's one of the reasons that they've
detached the meaning um or they've
conflated the meaning of price increases
with inflation, saying, "Well, we can
actually do inflation as long as we pass
it to the right people because they
won't spill it out into the public
economy where the CPI would go up."
>> What we're seeing currently are all
kinds of examples of how that is being
suppressed. And as I said on stage in
DC, the reality is that humanity has
been turned into the transmission fluid
to slow the motion of monetary inflation
into CPI and PPI. Um, you know, this is
the reality. We're the squishy bit in
the middle that can be compressed in
order to slow the the transmission
across into PE producer price index and
consumer price index, which seems to be
the thing that people think inflation
actually is. It's not. It's inflation
and money supply the end. But to bring
this back to Bitcoin,
I think that the point we'd all
therefore disagree, sorry, agree with is
that Bitcoin's incredible innovation was
the idea that you could do what we've
done with gold throughout human history
with a cryptographic puzzle because
well, right, so
getting back to the star exploding to
create gold, that is a
if you this gets into some more physical
theory, but if you look into um
what has occurred at the moment that
you've created a new arrangement such as
gold that's metastable as metastable as
gold is. You've passed through a one-way
function within the universe physically.
You're not going to go back to that.
You're not going to revert that um
within like theoretically it's possible
but the odds are incredibly unlikely. In
a similar way, when you have
succeeded in a cryptographic contest,
you have created a one-way mathematical
gateway which can now be, you know,
conferred the same utility that we've
given gold. In fact, much greater
utility because we can do it
electronically. And with modern
networks, this is that's a great thing.
We have computers, we have networks. um
we can confer to something like Bitcoin
the the properties of gold. We can see
the same properties there and we can
leverage that. So this is a really good
insight um that you know goes back to
the original uh Bitcoin paper.
The the hangup being that Bitcoin itself
uh the Bitcoin network is a proof of
concept network and it never really got
past that that proof of concept stage.
So you're you know it as you kind of led
into this conversation you were saying
Bitcoin doesn't really work well it
works to a limited degree but it breaks
the moment you try to adopt it broadly
because it just can't handle the the
transaction volume. There's also issues
with you know the the way that the block
structure is designed is the way that
you would do a proof of concept. You
don't know all the details of the system
yet. you haven't played with the idea
fully yet and so you make kind of a glom
together data structure and so the block
that carries the cryptographic proof
also carries all the transactions and
everything can only possibly travel at
the pace of that block speed. Um there
are separation of concerns issues that
you would want to apply to this to break
that structure up and uh make the try
when I say separation of concerns in
design we try to do something like the
cryptographic proof that does the leader
selection you would want to separate
that from the actual work of including
transactions into the ledger. Um, and
that's something that that's a stage
that Bitcoin never got to because by the
time somebody was,
you know, buying pizzas with it, the
famous example, um, once things like
that started to sort of catch on and
people thought, hey, this might go
somewhere, suddenly you have a value to
Bitcoin, people make exchanges, now you
can't change the network at all.
>> So, the the definition got locked.
>> We've seen this twice over, but I'll
I'll come back to that in a second. Um I
think just to cap this point off what is
real money and and we say this in our
own materials that money based upon a
finite resource that can be proven whose
extraction has a value i.e. gold or an
cryptographic puzzle, not debaseable,
not sensorable, tradable between peers
without intermediation. And over and
over again, I keep going to events in
Zoo and various other places where
people are busy telling us that Bitcoin
is their great inspiration and that this
is amazing and isn't it wonderful and
then proceed to go on as if the title of
the paper didn't exist nor did any of
the content
>> because the title says ah peer-to-peer
electronic cash system. Our joke with
the Gaju is that we are the peer-to-peer
electronic cash system for
interplanetary use in the next 5,000
years,
which is also from my little dig at
Daniel Greyber and his uh whole thing
about debt, the story of money for the
last 5,000 years. Um
the the thing that I mean I think we can
all we we've we've said it a few times.
Satoshi's great innovation was to see
that a cryptographic puzzle could be
exactly the same
test of value, test of of of real money
as gold had been in the past and
certainly
>> and finitness because like we could
agree that a medium of exchange is
anything we agree is going to have a
future value that we were willing to
trade today. Okay. But when you get to
real money, you now have this new barter
pass which is that nobody can just
arbitrarily,
you know, bomb it with inflation,
>> right?
>> And in in the go. So at some point
gold's going to fall apart because
there's trillions of tons of gold just
floating around in space.
>> Well, going to space that's a problem.
>> That's that's why dear brother Musk is
exploring space is not because it's
entertaining. It's because he thinks he
can get a hold of a few asteroids and
mine them. But um
the the uh the the reality is that
gold is never going to be as good a tool
for this as a cryptographic puzzle
because you know you alluded to this
earlier. We talked about the the
inflation of supply that about 2% more
gold perom is added in a retrospective
nice slidy graph type approach. Uh
obviously there were periods where there
was a great deal more supply and then
the price of gold would collapse as a
result. But um
with a cryptographic puzzle, you can as
we have with the gajim maru design that
to operate in a very clear way for all
sorts of different reasons which we'll
get into. For example, why are there one
trillion gajus? Well, why is there $100
trillion worth of uh private debt in the
world? Uh why is there way more than
that in terms of public debt? It's uh
it's it's pretty phenomenal. But as
we'll come to in a minute, the IMF is
very busy driving the agenda that we
should continue to create public debt.
Debt to whom? By whom? For whom? I have
no idea. Neither do they. Um what you
touched on there though was that
really Bitcoin along with Ethereum,
they're two massive proofs of concept.
Uh, and I'm I'm not sure that with the
the the idea that Satoshi did not or
whoever Satoshi was, whether it was a
group of people or a person, the idea
that they were unaware that this is a
proof of concept is just mind-blowing to
me because it's it seems obvious that it
is a proof of concept. the fact that it
launched, it ran, uh, meant that it
couldn't be brought back because, as you
point out in its entire genesis was this
idea that it once once it's running,
it's running. That's it. You you
>> you can only make so many changes. I
mean, this is why we're holding off on
public access to mining is so that we
continue to push updates into the chain
after the base has been formed. Um, so
why do we call it a proof of concept? I
mean I think you can probably speak very
well to this. Why do we refer to Bitcoin
and Ethereum but focusing on Bitcoin
right now as a proof of concept and you
why is it a square wheel?
>> So
I mean the um what we've talked about so
far for example is the using the
cryptographic puzzle as essentially a
way to print money at a controlled rate.
And this is actually also how the
algorithm works on any blockchain. It's
no matter how much mining power you
throw at it,
uh you can't print money faster
because the algorithm is going to self
adjust uh adjust the difficulty of the
puzzle so that you you stick to the same
money printing rate. Now [clears throat]
the mining algorithm also
uh serves a a different purpose in that
um if because it's a peer-to-peer
transaction system. It was intended as a
peer-to-peer transaction system. Um the
way to ensure that people don't do stuff
like double spend attack which is
essentially rewriting the history of the
chain.
Um you have to have a lot of mining
power so that it's really expensive to
create a block. Um
and uh in the early days of Bitcoin that
didn't really matter because nobody
really used it for something for
anything. Well, uh I guess someone
bought pizzas for what was it? 30
bitcoins, which is kind of cute today.
Um
>> $3 million pizza.
>> If if the currency that you're printing
is going to be worth something, you also
need to be able to transact with that.
That's the other part of the Bitcoin
uh idea that you can store transactions
on the chain. they are included in
blocks. Um, and essentially it becomes a
ledger that you can't modify which makes
it safe which guarantees the uh the
transactions
but the way Bitcoin was designed um
these blocks are produced
10 minutes apart.
So it means that typically
if you're lucky and your transaction
gets into the next block typically you'd
have to wait like six minutes on average
I think right now um
for the transaction to end up on the
chain and uh also blocks are limited in
size which means that theoretically
nowadays since they've increased the
maximum imum block ch block block size
uh you could p push bitcoin to 22
transactions per second I think
theoretically
in practice it's limited to 3 to seven
transactions per second
>> has it ever hit seven
>> it actually
>> people always number three to seven but
I think the reality is three to four
>> well I mean
depending depending on how you measure
performance. Like uh in um
peak performance, if you look at like
one or two blocks that happen to be full
of transactions,
um you might you will find uh some uh
spikes that go up to maybe 11 11 12
transactions per second, but that's peak
rate for a few minutes. Um
in practice
it tends to
um
back when I worked in telecoms we used
to talk about engineered capacity. Peak
rate is also important especially when
you recover from failure and stuff like
that. But normally you want to know what
the steady state rate is that you can
that you can manage. And uh and for
Bitcoin that seems to be
3 to seven transactions per se per
second. And uh
now if you go above that what happens is
your transactions won't be included like
for example and this essentially what
you can do is you can pay a higher fee
which is uh awarded to whoever
whichever minor includes your
transaction in the block. So essentially
the highest bidder gets to get included
in a block. And for example, today
if you stick to the minimum allowed fee
on Bitcoin,
the estimation is that it will take
about 24 hours for your transaction to
be included in a block.
And interestingly, blocks are not filled
to the maximum. They tend to be filled
to like one megabyte out of four. Uh so
exactly the technicalities around that I
don't really know what what they are why
they don't fill it fill them to the brim
when they could. So you you tend to have
like 10,000 transactions waiting in the
meool and then you have blocks that are
filled to like a quarter of a third of
maximum capacity.
But that seems to be the way they roll.
Um, now the obvious problem with this is
that if Bitcoin would take off as a
popular payment medium, the chain would
immediately get saturated
and fees would get crazy high.
Uh,
so
essentially it kind of works because no
one is using it as a payment medium
except for essentially settlements
between crypto exchanges for the most
part.
And um
>> well I mean that that's that's a that's
a whole other thing that we'll come to
in a minute is that everything that's uh
tried to make this work effectively is a
dirty hack. Uh and there are uh actual
um code hacks uh like lightning runes,
ordinals, bitcoin os and there's other
hacks just interesting exchanges that
provide all the intermediation and the
question of whether there's any
liquidity in bitcoin or whether it
actually is a store of value is is
really down to how much cash do these um
exchanges hold against that bitcoin. And
the answer is we don't know because
they're not audited, accounted for, or
regulated. Anyway, sorry, go back. Also,
>> so another interesting thing that
happened was that the Bitcoin community
very quickly decided that
uh it was going to be too hard to evolve
the implementation.
Um
so for example the the protocol we are
using in the Gajumaru chain Bitcoin NG
was proposed as a way to
radically increase the throughput of the
Bitcoin chain but it wasn't adopted by
Bitcoin because they felt that it would
be too big a change. Well, no. They were
making far too much money out of
creating FOMO around Bitcoin prices. And
really what they wanted to do was just
keep playing that game. And once they
realized it really couldn't, they
couldn't win the currency argument, they
wanted to move to this furious score
store of value argument,
>> which is an interesting thing uh aspect
of technology development. It's kind of
like uh you know movie actors being typ
cast into
a certain role that they then end up
playing their entire career because not
because they couldn't possibly
u act in any other way. It's like no one
is asking them to. And um so if you have
a a community in technology that finds a
niche that works for them, that tends to
be what defines the technology.
>> Uh
>> that was an incredibly generous
assessment of and and entirely lacking
in the cynicism of mine.
But you are my specialy in this group.
[laughter]
>> But it it sort of it happens all the
time. Um in uh as Erlang programmers,
Craig and I are have spent a lot of time
in the programming Erlang programming
language community. One of the things
that has been almost impossible to
um to evolve in the Erlang community is
a good graphics library because Erlang
programmers you don't come to Erling to
do uh guey programming.
So it's not like you couldn't do it in
in Erling. Of course, you could you
could do it extremely well, which has
been demonstrated in in principle. It's
just that not enough people are
interested to form sort of a sub
community around that and and create
enough momentum to get it good enough
for others to adopt it and start using
it. And uh it's it that's more a
community dynamic thing that
the people using a technology and what
they come there for
uh
where sort of their priorities go define
what can actually be done with that
technology. Not not in that it couldn't
theoretically be used in any different
way. It's just the community is going to
resist your attempts to try to do it.
Yeah, look, I I as I said, I think
you're being incredibly generous to
people who have um really struck out to
be Shanghai billionaires, which is a
point we'll come to a bit later.
>> Well, that's a business case, too, isn't
it?
>> Well, I I I think I think the business
case has has driven the agenda rather
than the technological case. And I I I
feel like a lot of the conversations I
have with Bitcoiners aren't really
understand. I mean, as I say over and
over again, uh, at various events in the
last three years, especially, last six
years, in fact, but, you know, I I still
see it. I still see people constantly
talking about, oh, the Bitcoin white
paper was such an inspiration to me. And
so I decided to ignore everything in it
and create a layer two
because you know one of the key things
that we said you know is the definition
of money it's tradable peerto peer
um tradable between peers without
intermediation. Uh you know I don't know
how people can talk about the Bitcoin
white paper and completely avoid that
point. It's it's fundamental to what it
was about. It was about literally in the
title
a peer-to-peer not peer to broto peer
electronic c cash settlement. Um
it really really blows my mind that all
of these very basic things that are
publicly available everywhere. you know,
you type in Bitcoin white paper into the
into any search engine and it will find
it and the title will appear before you.
It the title is not there just for shits
and giggles. It it's there because it's
describing what this thing is meant to
be. Um so I I guess that segus us quite
neatly to the question I would then ask
is why are all attempts to make the
square wheel which is the proof of
concept that it cannot evolve beyond
for many reasons both technological
adoption community but I would argue
more fundamentally cynical business or
cynical not business that's not the way
business should be done
why are all of the attempts to change it
doomed what is the technical impediment
to any real change despite what Larry
think may think. Why can't Bitcoin be
changed?
Uh
because it isn't
it goes back to the point of of real
money. Actually, this is sort of the the
catch that you get into with real money
in a digital context is that uh the
reason gold was a good uh a good
unfakeable thing is that it's
ungovernable
to kind of parody the meme. Um
[clears throat] it's already there. You
can't fake it. You can only get so much
at a time because it's hard to get a
hold of. Uh when it comes to Bitcoin,
it's also ungovernable in the sense that
the network already exists and if you
want to change the network, you have to
convince everybody running mining nodes
to come and join your new version of it.
So that's where you get to the the hard
fork problem uh where you have to
convince everyone a critical mass of
people. You have to convince them to
take this history of the chain and we're
going to all at once switch to this new
thing, whatever the change is, uh, and
and continue down that path.
And you're not going to convince people.
They're all going to infight over
because there's no leader. Um,
there's no and everyone disagrees on
what optimum means. uh in addition to a
critical mass of people who don't really
understand Bitcoin but they're terrified
of changing it which is not an
unreasonable fear if you don't
understand something if something's been
working for you so far you don't really
understand it you understand enough to
just like get by with you don't really
know you know
how the block candidates are created you
don't know the details of like how the
memp pools being you know um sorted
through or sorted by different different
uh um well at this point pool leaders
because pretty much nobody mines a
bitcoin by themselves or a block by
themselves anymore. Um, if you're not in
the details of all that, you don't
really understand the details of that,
you don't understand what the hack is
that allowed uh lightning to to be
created and um don't really understand
exactly the details of what's going on
with things like ordinals or runes. You
don't understand it to that level. You
would be scared of a new change coming
in. It's a change that you don't
understand on top of a system you don't
fully understand, but you know that
whatever you've got right now is working
for you. And so there's a resistance to
change. And people don't like new stuff
typically. Um so it's almost impossible,
categorically impossible to convince a
critical mass, you know, the bulk of
people doing Bitcoin to agree to a fork
that is got whatever your favorite
change happens to be. Um
>> unless it's carefully crafted
incremental updates, you [clears throat]
can do that.
>> Yeah.
>> But but essentially you have to
>> you have to show that it's actually
worth it to even make the incremental
upgrades. So there aren't that many of
those either. Um and
>> there have been upgrades to to Bitcoin,
>> right? But the changes we're talking
about that would make it like practical
are huge
>> would would be a complete rebuild.
>> Yeah.
>> Or I got you. Well, maybe not a complete
rebuild, but like you could still have
the Bitcoin protocol up to now and then
do something very different is the next
step. But getting people to agree to a
large a large enough change to do things
like
like what what the minor could do,
that's just that's just not going to
happen. There's a social problem
connected to this. It's just not going
to happen because of the the social
structure around it. And and that does
come down come down to consensus that
consensus is hard to reach. The way that
we've offloaded consensus is automated
consensus, algorithmic consensus, but
getting everyone to agree on a radical
technical move, that's not really a
thing. And and there is a this is a
there is a business dynamic to this that
uh I guess most companies will recognize
as well that if you if you try to go to
your customers with a massive upgrade
that's not really it's essentially a
totally new system. We used to back in
telecoms, we used to call that forklift
upgrades, which basically means you have
to
remove the the old telephone switch and
put a new one in. Uh the thought that
you're going to trigger in the
customer's mind is that, oh, this is a
really good time to start looking at
what the competition has to offer,
>> right?
>> Because you want to put in an entirely
new system, so why shouldn't I put in
your your competitors? else is entirely
new.
>> It's going to be the same amount of work
because
it's not incremental. So this is what
you want to avoid at all cost. do not
>> actually sorry to interrupt because you
you you talked about this very
interestingly in the context of
decisions that were made around PCs and
what you see from that is that
incremental
continuation of the mistake because
there wasn't a desire to say no let's do
this the right way from the beginning
it's a really good example of exactly
what you're talking about so maybe maybe
talk to that
>> yeah the um the story of how the IBM
piece PC came to be is
>> is really amazing. There are some good
books written about it. Uh PC magazine
had some really good series of articles.
Um the um I mean essentially IBM came
into the party late. There were uh some
sort of hobby computer rigs that people
could buy. Uh but and Apple had the
Apple 2 at the time, which was then a
pretty well-crafted um machine, but IBM
noticed that
Apple didn't really have the the muscle
and the marketing smarts to put that on
every uh
every desk out in in businesses. So they
figured that yeah, we could actually if
we could build it, we could market the
hell out of it. Except they realized
that with the IBM culture at the time,
they couldn't build a personal computer.
It's too too small, too dinky, too fast
moving. So what they did was they
allowed a small [snorts] team
uh to just ignore all the IBM procedures
and culture and just try to build a
prototype. And they actually were given
30 days to come up with at least a proof
of concept. And um so they managed to do
that 12 man team in 30 days they built a
working computer. Absolutely awesome.
And uh then they got another two months
to build a production prototype. And the
idea was to actually launch the machine
within a year from project start. And of
course if you and also they realized
that for once they weren't actually
going to build all the parts themselves.
So they had to just go out and try to
cobble something together from what
already existed.
And so for example, that's why how they
ended up with the Intel chip because
they were used to the they knew about
the 8080 uh architecture already. Intel
had sort of made a
cludgy
version of the 8080 that was sort of
could be a 16bit chip to compete with,
for example, Motorola. The Motorola
68000 was built from the ground up as a
really good 16bit
uh CPU with a good instruction set. This
is one thing you learn in engineering
school when they want to teach you about
CPU architectures. They're going to
teach the 68000 architecture rather than
the Intel architecture because the Intel
architecture is so messy. Uh because
there were so many compromises made. But
IBM, yeah, they knew that the 68,000 was
nicer and Apple was using that, but they
didn't have the time. Uh, they stuck
with the the 8080. Well, actually, they
didn't go with the 8086,
uh, which was at least the nicer version
because it was too powerful and it might
compete with IBM's own product line. So
then they took the lowcost 8088 instead
uh which is sort of an 8bit 16- bit
hybrid. So that was one thing, but then
they also needed an OS for it. And
well, there was an operating system
called CPM that most hobbyists were
using. But I think the guy who
uh had built that, well, the stories
diverge a little bit depending on the
ego of the person telling it, I guess,
but one version is that he just flipped
IBM off and went flying in his private
plane instead. and and they left the
meeting
sort of flumxed and um eventually Bill
Gates
managed to get a buddy who had ported
or built a clone of CPM from the
reference manuals
16bit version uh to give it to to
Microsoft essentially not telling him
why they wanted it and then they
licensed it to IBM.
Um, and that version actually was called
quick and dirty operating system because
it was just a stop gap to be able to
have an operating system for the
computers that he was uh that Seattle
computer was trying to build. So, it's
an amazing story of just all these
prototypes hastily cobbled together and
then launched as
sort of a business computer
which then just exploded and became a
huge success. And one thing that they
had done which was nice was they decided
that they wanted to do an open
architecture which actually opened the
door to a huge clone market. That wasn't
actually what they intended but a lot of
companies started building IBM
compatible clones and the test actually
for whether you were IBM compatible was
if you could run the flight simulator
program then it was compatible.
I I I remember I had a 286. It was my
pride and joy. It had a 20 megabyte hard
drive. And uh I played a game called
Elite on it, which um people may or may
not remember. And then the one that I
remember being the big breakthrough was
Falcon. Falcon. It was just called
Falcon. You were flying an F-16 around
the place. Um [clears throat] but
>> yeah and uh but the interesting thing
then was that they conquered the market
completely
and then we saw decades of having to
work around all these crazy design
decisions
like weird memory management and memory
limits uh all kinds of stuff like long
into the history of Windows
you still had the 640k
memory limit which you could then had to
sort of escape and try to use extended
memory. I don't know was it Windows 95
or something that finally uh did away
with that but it was it took forever.
>> I think it was 98. I think 95 still had
the uh you were still based on DOSs and
then Windows when you
>> Windows did its own preeemption
>> because you just because the DOSs way of
control was just like we're giving you
the whole system now don't crash
>> 95 would boot to DOSs and then boot
Windows
>> right so
>> but the the cool thing is I guess that
they still conquered the market because
[clears throat] they actually offered
something that
had unique utility
And initially you could run visical on
the PC and uh which
>> text word perfect and stuff was like a
big deal actually.
>> Yeah, you could run word processing on
it and uh it was actually a real machine
that you could buy from a real company.
You could buy it at Sears and Compu
computer
>> store
>> comput store. Uh and
uh so it just launched a business
revolution. Now you could say that to
bring it back to Bitcoin, Bitcoin is
kind of similar to Q DOS in that sense.
the Q dos of blockchain but
it didn't really revolutionize
uh
>> hold on would to extend your analogy it
is cudos but it's it's closed it's a
closed code base so actually the guy who
wrote cudos closed the locked the whole
system threw away the key and walked
away is that a fair analogy to
Well,
I I know Bitcoin is open, but I'm just
saying in in terms of how incapable it
is of evolving, you know, answering the
point I was asking about, why are all
attempts to make the square wheel round
doomed?
So I guess one one thing I would say is
that
the thing that drove
evolution of you know from Q dos to the
PC systems that we have today is that
you actually had real users
uh a real market uh a real demand for
change. [clears throat]
So there there was a real business case
in trying to
essentially spending huge amounts of uh
engineering
resources into
slowly morphing this to keep up with
demand.
Uh
and I guess in one sense you it was an
interesting duality because you had
Apple
which in contrast then they spent five
years designing the Macintosh toolbox
to make it really coherent and
wellcrafted. It was a really amazing
engineering feat. is like you would buy
Macintosh computers
that I mean they had all the
plugandplay. I remember back then
we who were using Macintoshes thought it
was hilarious when PC magazine had an
entire issue dedicated to making
plugandplay work on Windows and of
course Apple had had plugandplay for
years. Um and things like postgris
printing uh [clears throat] or postcript
printing um laser printers, scuzzy
buses, external hard drives, all those
things were actually innovations that
came out of Apple and then essentially
the PC world caught up um
because
there was actually a market for
competing systems that offered
technology innovations. So if you wanted
to be sort of in the no and be on the
forefront of technology development
essentially you would be with Apple. Now
they were
kind of awful to be a developer for
because it was so much top down control
but architecturally it was great. And I
remember we had um some of the computers
we had like the Macintosh 2X or whatever
when we bought it or the Macintosh 2 uh
when we bought it you couldn't actually
get a color monitor.
There weren't any color monitors but
when they came out and you could buy a
color monitor. Turned out your old
Macintosh that was developed before the
color monitors actually supported color
and that was the typical Macintosh
experience. It's like the the continuity
was absolutely amazing.
So that was an incredibly well-crafted
system and I think in a way it made
it sort of set the standard for the PC
world to catch up with for a long time
for decades
which was a cool dynamic but the
underlying force that you don't really
didn't really see with Bitcoin was that
people actually ran with it and they
wanted to do stuff with it and that's
what created
the innovation.
Uh
>> hold on. I I I think people did try and
do things with Bitcoin. They did try.
>> It just didn't work and they
>> true. I think there were a number of
reasons why it could not evolve to work
in the way you know the story you tell
of how we ended up with today's PCs was
a story of adoption and demand for
change and by making the system open IBM
were effectively forced into a race to
build the best systems
>> something they arguably lost because
they ended up selling their entire PC
building business to the Chinese. Um,
but that innovation was was pushing for
betterment all of the time. Uh, there
were many impediments to it. But I I
think with Bitcoin, there were people
who were genuinely trying to find a way
of using it. and
the those who were profiting most from
its manipulation or if you want to be
kind its appreciation in in price. Uh
and you'll note I did not use the word
value. Um
they they really invested a lot of that
money into what we would call dirty
hacks. So Craig, what when we refer to
things like lightning network, runes,
ordinals, and Bitcoin OS as dirty hacks,
what do we mean?
So a hack
in this sense like hack has today been
conflated with the term crack. That's a
security one, right? Um, but a hack on a
system would be you take some some
aspect of a system that exists uh that
you've realized you can use in a way
that it was never intended to be used
for but get an effect that you want. And
in Bitcoin, there's a few of these. Um,
there are a couple of uh multi-
signature schemes that Bitcoin supports.
Well, that's sort of been abused to
create not quite a state channel, which
is sort of the basis for the lightning
network, an amalgam. But so once man,
lightning network is like its own
universe of things to explore. Um,
basically there's two ways to do uh so,
okay, bit, let me start back. Bitcoin is
a little bit too slow. A little bit,
it's way too slow. Um it's any slow
motion put kindness bug might be moving
from all the way across to Japan to you
at this rate.
>> Well maybe he'll get infected with my
[laughter]
say harsh things disease. Um
>> actually I had one tiny point that I
want to squeeze in here that just to
finish the sort of Q do analogy. One
thing about the many limitations of the
initial PCs was that it was a local
problem to whoever was using I mean you
bought a PC and you dealt with the
limitations in your house in your
business and then if it didn't wasn't
sufficient you would go elsewhere and
and solve your problem with other tools.
M
>> the problem with the the radical
limitations of Bitcoin
are at the core of what would
theoretically be a global finance and
retail network
and and then it becomes
an absolutely ridiculous limit that you
can only run like
>> well less than 10 transactions per
second. So you get you get a lower a
lowest common denominator problem
because you have network effect. So,
like imagine in old PC days, I want to
add a sound card to my computer
and it's doing a certain type of sound
modulation
and you've gone on ahead and got
something from remember Creative Labs,
they did the sound sound blaster cards
and it was like this amazing thing. You
could play arbitrary sounds and they
weren't just like emulated, you know,
they weren't just pure modulated sounds.
You could do a lot of different things
with it. If I want to use this one and
you want to use that one, but we're in a
network together where they all have to
work at the same time, we have to agree
on one. And if we're not going to agree
on one, well, nobody can have sound.
Now, that's sort of the the that's not
the situation with PCs. You could
individually do this because you weren't
affecting each other. But in the Bitcoin
network, you are you to come up with a
new advancement on Bitcoin, everybody
would have to agree the same change, and
that's not going to happen.
So whatever the original limitation was
in a PC, well I could just take my own
PC, do some crazy thing with it, make my
own hardware for it if I'm a mega nerd
and do my own thing and it doesn't hurt
computer at all. But in the Bitcoin
network, it's different. He's running a
node. It's talking to my node. They both
have to speak the same language and all
this has to be represented on chain in a
common way. They both have to understand
that. And it's not just us. It's the
whole network has to understand whatever
we're putting into a block. So that
that's a again it's a really hard pro.
Even communicating to people that
there's a change coming that we need to
upgrade together and we're going to do
it at this time. Even just coordinating
that across like the planet is not easy.
>> So these become sticky limitations that
just reside forever.
>> So you wind up with hacks is the only
way to advance the state of the art. To
be fair, I think if Satoshi was a known
person or persons
that he could have built the trust to
say, I want to push something new to the
network. This is what it is. This is
what it's going to do. It's going to be
completely open. I I I think part of the
problem with Bitcoin was the anonymity
of Satoshi because that meant that you
couldn't vest trust in somebody through
their actions, through their behaviors.
I'm not saying that we should just trust
somebody because they are a nice person.
You know what I said on stage in
Likenstein stands. No matter how nice
you think anybody in QPQ is, you can
never let us have keys to the kingdom.
Our whole point is we will burn the keys
to the kingdom.
>> Um,
>> right.
But you can trust us during the
bootstrapping phase because it's clearly
in our interest to try to be honest
brokers until at least we've captured
your attention.
>> Then you shouldn't trust us anymore
because our incentives will change.
>> You look at our our our development
plans over the next 18 months and
they're enormous. There's a huge amount
we want to push into this chain to make
available to everybody for free as part
of the process. and and our opinion is
that this makes it the one resource
layer that will ever exist. Uh you know,
we we talk about it being interplanetary
buddy for the next 5,000 years. Probably
more than that actually, but you know,
the point is we need to build all of
that all of those tools, all of those
capabilities into the system through
rapid iteration over the next 18 months.
Beyond that 18 months, there will be
upgrades to the system and to some
extent there will be some degree to
which we will be able to shape that but
not control it, not direct it, not
govern it. But certainly we would have a
degree of shaping capacity and the fact
that we are public people when you know
we're not hiding who we are. We're not
hiding what our agendas are. All of our
videos going back however many years at
that point will be in the public domain
saying good things and bad things. I
think that would give people a basis to
go well actually we'll take a look at
what it is you're suggesting. Not that
we can give orders but that we can
suggest look this is a change we think
we should implement. Here's why. And I
mean I know you always laugh Craig when
I say that oh yeah so there's a bunch of
libertarians in the room and nobody
agreed on anything. [laughter]
That's but that's that's a thing. That's
a dynamic.
>> It kind of is. And I think it's it's
it's why the the libertarian agenda has
never really found uh a strong enough
singular voice to challenge the
socialist agenda of well, hey, it's his
fault that you're poor. Let's just tax
him and give you the money. But um
>> there's an asymmetry there that goes
back to the like the sort of the roots
of philosophic entropism too, which is
that it's very easy to define what's
bad.
It's very hard to define what's good.
>> We don't agree on that. But it's easy to
to define, you know, burn the building
down. Well, that sucks. Okay, let's
renovate the bathroom. What color should
it be? Oh man, that's never going to be
sorted out. Um but we know that burning
it down is bad. Definitely bad. So
you've got this asymmetry in goodness.
There's like a directionality.
Uh there's a directional arrow of of
ease of identification. You go, well,
burning everything down that sucks.
Let's do something good. However, I'm
going to give I'm going to [snorts] give
your kid a car. You'd be like, man,
that's awesome. I'm going to give your
kid a, you know, and then I name
something that you just absolutely hate.
like, well, it was going to be free, but
you hate it. So, you know that you get
to these weird weird corner cases and
there's just zillions of them and you're
never going to get them all ironed out.
Uh, and you have to get them ironed out
in detail to do a technical system.
Socially, you can you can just give each
other slack like ah, you don't you like
different stuff than I like. I don't
care. But in a technical system, you all
have to agree they can't talk to each
other.
>> Yeah. to to your point about sound
blasters. You you know if everybody
agrees to have one, then everyone can
have sound in a network system. If
somebody says, "No, I want the acce
one," then
>> hey presto, nobody can have sound. Um
>> Right.
>> It's so easy to throw that trip wire
out.
>> Yeah. But
>> the thing about dirty hacks, uh it's
kind of like with um
when you build systems, and it's not
just technology. It's the same thing if
you're trying to build a house, for
example. You have to decide which walls
are going to support the entire
structure.
Uh, and supporting walls, you you don't
just knock them down, uh, willy-nilly,
unless it's a Faulty towers episode,
[clears throat]
which was a hilarious one. Um, but
the, um, so this is where, for example,
Bitcoin came out in 2009. Uh, and then
some people started thinking that, hey,
you could actually do other things other
than payments on a blockchain like smart
contracts. And then Ethereum, which was
another prototype, came out in 2013,
right? Um, demonstrating how you could
actually run snippets of code on a
blockchain. Um, now
Bitcoin didn't just jump onto that
bandwagon. You can you can write some
scripts uh on Bitcoin that add a little
bit of functionality to a transaction,
but you can't run smart contracts. Um,
and even though it's 11 years later,
like 11 years after
the smart contracts were introduced on a
blockchain system,
uh, Bitcoin still doesn't support smart
contracts. Um because
adding smart contract functionality to
the Bitcoin chain would be such a
fundamental change that it would be an
entirely new system.
>> Mhm.
>> And again, [clears throat] we're it's a
forklift upgrade. Essentially, you're
just switching to an entirely different
architecture and it's just too hard to
do.
>> I But I I come back to my point. I I
think if if Satoshi was a known person
or persons, there might have been more
capacity for him to have said to the
community, I really want to implement
this change. Has anybody got a better
idea? Yes, I do. Great. Okay, let's
let's look at this together and then
begin to implement. have been, as you
both point out, incremental adaptations
to the Bitcoin uh system, but it's been
so incremental and and everything we're
seeing else we call a dirty hack, which
I'll come back to in a second.
I sometimes wonder if this is why there
is this cult of personality that you see
perpetuating the entire crypto space.
One of you guys touched on it this
morning with runes. Um I I personally
really don't like it. you know this
whole thing of deifying the founder as
if the founder exists in isolation much
like Jesus Christ came to earth in
isolation. Uh it it makes me very
uncomfortable because um you know I I
sit in our team and I often feel like
the dumbest person in the room. Um
the reality is everything that you see
in what we do is um is crafted from
extensive discussions, [snorts] debates.
Um you know, some of you guys have
probably read entire libraries. Um and
all of those things that you've brought
in from all these different walks of
life that all of us have brought in from
all these different walks of life are
actually where the collision has
occurred that has led to the gajimaru
and not just the gajimaru but everything
else we want to do on top of that around
that beyond that um and I
>> I don't know by comparison for example
the ethereum chain that introduced smart
contracts they also built an entire
foundation. There was actually a living
known founder. And if you look at how
much innovation happened in the Ethereum
space,
uh it vastly outpaced the innovation in
the Bitcoin space.
>> Yeah. But it also uh corrupted and
corrupted. Absolutely.
>> Yeah. It has its own problems. But in
terms of [laughter]
>> that's again sadly
>> the diplomat of QPQ does speak.
[laughter]
No, no, just to um like you said, it's a
I think it's a really valid point that
it it helps to explain why Bitcoin has
been so extremely conservative
and why some of those
sort of disruptive changes simply could
not
could not be made because essentially
they ended up in the trap of a bunch of
religious libertarians.
um
>> arguing over almost guy to shoot up
fentanyl in the in the public.
>> What Satoshi's vision really was and you
can't speak to Satoshi except some
people have actually claimed to be
Satoshi. Anyway,
>> yeah, look, [snorts] I I think
ultimately this is why we come back to
this point about dirty hacks that what
we've ended up with is instead of
wholesale adaptation to a schedule or a
plan, which is, you know, we have to be
honest, we only have 18 months of that.
Beyond that, we intend to make this
completely open and public and and then
at best we are an influencer of change.
We're not a a driver. Um,
>> I I'd like to point out one really
important point though, and this is I
mean you guys know this, but people
listening might not that the whole like
I'm really happy with the way that the
design for AC's came out where we can
sort of seal off the the brute, you
know, where the money's meant and say
this is [clears throat] a static
definition beyond our whitelist phase,
but then if we want to someone comes up
with a crazy idea to do something, you
can just instead of having to do dirty
hacks, you can foster very deliberate
innovation within an AC. And that AC can
be the peak of a whole a whole tree of
its own stuff. Um, which can do whatever
it wants within the the within the the
general context of the Gotcha Mer, which
is great. And I think that's going to
probably wind up being one of the killer
features
because you can get away from the hack
space which which has its crazy own
limitations. um along with the thing
that Ol again these are things that as
we were coming up with them we didn't
realize how significant they were but I
come back again to that thing where
realized one day he's like hey the
associate chain design kind of lends
itself to working with regulators
because you could have a known operator
and say hey regulatory body if I can I
register to run a regulated chain in
this space or not um whether or not that
requires declaration of a new currency
and this is the route for that And uh I
think that combination being able to
innovate on an AC without having to have
the whole group agree with whatever that
you know the AC's innovation is uh plus
regulatory compliance. That's I think
that's really going to be the the two
>> Yeah. I mean
>> those two factors kind of promote
success. The the key to what we've done
is that we're saying that Groot, the the
resource layer, is open,
governance-free,
you know, non-debatable.
>> Sorry, I [clears throat] think the the
definition we use is is actually pretty
good on this one. Um,
a an uncontrolled shared ledger where
the history cannot be changed, that is
resistant to censorship. There is no
operator that you have to trust. That
that is group. That is the core of of
this. And that's the bit that I explain
to people is is Bitcoin made tens of
thousands of times more efficient with
native smart contracts and native uh
virtual machines. Um the the real
innovation, you know, a lot of what we
did was adopted from eternity. Um and
Eternity had was starting to go down the
road of um I forget what they called
them, but a similar sort of idea. I'd
been with QPQ, the first iteration of
QPQ where we'd built something called
one DLT. And the idea was was sort of
similar that you would create a specific
blockchain for a specific industry or
purpose that would now in the 1DT
instance it was it was fatally flawed,
but we didn't know that at the time. At
the time, it was way ahead of everything
else. And now a lot of other people are
doing similar sort of things. But at its
core was this idea that you could take
um any virtual machine, any programmatic
language,
source consensus from different chains
and fuse it into effectively what was a
an infrastructure piece for an industry
for a nation state to use on a a
composable tool set basis. Uh what you
guys have been looking at with uh
Eternity at the time or previous to that
was forgive me what was it again that
they called it?
>> The hyper chain.
>> Hyperchains. Yeah.
>> Yeah. And it was a similar sort of idea
that you would have this space in which
specific industries or specific nation
states or specific requirements could be
addressed. And ultimately what it came
back to was this this fallacy in
blockchain that there is one answer to
solve everything. There there isn't. So
really, Groot doesn't solve everything.
Groot solves the problem of how do you
create real money that really works and
provide a backbone that allows
everything else to function cohesively
together. It's not solving every
problem. It's solving that problem.
>> Yes.
>> And you look at the infrastructure above
that, the associate chains, and what
they actually do is allow you to say,
well, I specifically don't want this
functionality. I do want that. uh I want
to have access to this but not that. So
for example, it might be the case that
the US government builds an associate
chain for the US dollar as being a
native currency and they say well we we
want to decide who's allowed to have
dollars.
That's their right. No, I mean genuinely
that's their right, right? Because they
they get to formulate this exactly as
they want it. So ulf you remember when
we were writing the patent for the
structure of the gajimaru one of the
things that you're identifying is that
actually infrastructure operators will
decide what can come in and what can
come out from the resource from group.
This is one of the key features because
in reality what we're saying is that
every single type of regulatory
environment, national environment,
industry environment, whatever you want
to call it, they're all trust markets of
different types. And within that, there
will be subsets of trust markets, each
of which needs a different model to
solve the problem. And that you're
right, that's the real killer feature.
It's not just that it's Bitcoin made
tens of thousands of times more
efficient with smart native smart
contract language and native virtual
machines. That's not the true killer
feature. The true killer feature is that
it's everything that, for example,
global layer 1 says that we need to have
in order to create a global uh
securities market. Well, here you go.
Here's all the tools. You know, it was
funny. I was at point0 last year and
they were on stage talking about how
they can formulate the ideas, but the
technology is way behind. And I was
trying to wave my hand and say, "No, no,
no. [laughter] The technology is right
here. We we built it. is exactly exactly
what you're asking for is what we've
made. But um uh I think you're you're
you know coming back to the dirty hack
point. I think your point that um by
creating a base and tool set that all of
this innovation can occur on that's how
we know that this can be a solution for
thousands of years because whatever
limitations Groot runs into if you're
doing transactions primarily in Groot 50
years from now you're doing it wrong. I
mean the state channels that all you
know [snorts] you you'll talk to very
well one day soon.
>> Um state channels will make that so much
more useful but even still you're still
doing things in the wrong place. They
should be at the infrastructure level.
That should be where the real innovation
is is allowed to occur. And and coming
back to the dirty hack point and I'm
pushing this over to you Wolf because I
know you've looked in quite some detail
at these things and also you Craig. Um
we have these dirty hacks. So you
explained what a hack is Craig. What's a
dirty hack and why do we refer to runes
oracles OS lightning network as being
dirty hacks? And it's not Greg wanting
to poke somebody in the eye. It really
isn't. I I actually left the room when
the guy from Bitcoin OS began to jump
around telling everybody how Bitcoin
inspired his entire life and then went
on to tell everybody that he had the
best layer 2, having obviously not read
the title or the the document.
What's a dirty hack?
Well, I mean,
some some hacks can actually be really
clever and elegant and uh where you
create something brilliant out of
something that was
not the original purpose. Um,
that would be an amazing hack. A dirty
hack is something that you'd rather not
let pe that people would peek into
because
[laughter]
and and it doesn't really unlock um
amazing. It it it doesn't go all the
way. It kind of lets you, it's the
sticks and duct tape version where it
lets you do something, but if you wanted
to do it for real, you'd actually have
to go back and redesign it. So, yeah,
comes
>> I can use these padding bits to define
extensions like maybe don't do that.
>> Yeah. So,
>> so to give it I was thinking about
>> a Lord of the Rings context
human being is you know men as Tolken
called them [clears throat] um is the
standard
a hack would be an elf a dirty hack
would be a goblin or an orc
>> kind of [laughter] yeah and then you
don't want to say like where do they
come don't it's gross don't look into
how they come to
So just one thing that I was thinking
while we were talking about this like
when we were talking about the the
brilliance of minting uh currency using
crypto puzzles and the actual wonderful
feature that you can't rush you can't
speed up the printing. It's actually uh
rate controlled so that no matter how
much you put into it, it's not going to
let you print money faster, which is
absolutely beautiful.
It also accidentally
limits the rate of traffic on the
blockchain because when you're minting,
you're actually producing blocks and
it's the only way to put transactions on
the chain in this in the Bitcoin
solution. And
so then the size of the block and the
frequency with which you can create
blocks which is limited because you want
to limit this is also how you print
money. You create a block you get
rewarded and that's how the the extra
money is created. So the rate limitation
for creating money also limits how how
many transactions you can put on the
block within a certain time frame which
is not necessarily a feature.
Um,
so that's where you're kind of stuck
with the
say less than 10 transactions per second
throughput, which also can
if if something happens that that forces
that triggers people to start using
Bitcoin a lot for a certain period, then
we've seen fees go up to over $100.
to be able to get a transaction included
on the chain. And and actually, if you
look at the times that it's sometimes
taken to get uh I actually have that
here.
>> Yeah, you had a really good graphic of
that you were showing us earlier.
>> The um average confirmation time, it
looks like it's really low here. Um but
if you
the really low part here it's 57 minutes
uh time it takes for a a transaction
average time it takes on this particular
day for a transaction to get included on
the chain. Here is a little spike. This
is actually 2500 minutes. And here
11,000 minutes. This is July to 2024.
So it's it's not like this is ancient
history for
>> this this is a repeated pattern.
>> Yes, it happens actually with some
regularity and even these small spikes
3,500
minutes.
>> Wow.
>> Get a transaction on the chain. I mean
it's [snorts]
>> Yeah. I think uh posted a transaction on
as a a test transaction on um on Bitcoin
and it was a tiny I can't remember all
the details but you guys might it took
days to be confirmed.
Yeah. And so
this is where like for example
with the lightning network,
one reason, one thing that the lightning
network adds is that you can do really
fast uh payments.
Um and the dirty hack is that
essentially
the a channel on the lightning network
which is a onetoone channel birectional.
You create that by creating a
transaction, a funding transaction on
the chain that has some where both
parties sort of lock some funds into
that transaction
and then essentially you can do the way
that transaction is is set up with some
scripting is that you can then follow it
up with
a final transaction that shifts the
balance of funds. So you can reshuffle
the funds in that transaction
and and the way lightning works is that
it allows and it it has to be co-signed.
So both parties need to sign the
transaction and then the lightning
protocol allows the parties to
create new final transactions
essentially but not put them on the
chain. So they can just exchange those
and then there is a version number that
keeps getting incremented. So
you can then post the final transaction
on chain and commit the change
imbalance.
Um
the thing with Bitcoin when you do this
on on Bitcoin is that for one thing if
you want to do cheap and fast
transactions obviously you cannot do it
on the chain because it's neither cheap
nor fast. Um so with lightning you could
but it basically becomes your only
option because going to the chain would
be ridiculous.
Um
now one thing that makes it a dirty hack
is that
if you want to do state channels
um for one thing
creating the funding transaction as
we've seen can in worst case take
several days before it's actually put on
chain. Um,
but normally it would take maybe an hour
before it's secure on chain and and you
could do it
update it. So you can't top it up like
you can with your typical coffee shop
card. I think a coffee shop card would
be an in reasonable analogy to a state
channel. You you lock funds into your
coffee shop card and then you can use
that easily. just swipe it when you go
to the right coffee shop and then when
you run out of funds you can top it up
and that takes a little bit longer. You
have to pull up your credit card and
blah blah blah. It takes a little bit
longer but um and also it's the
annoyance for you that you lock up funds
into that card that you can't easily use
for anything else. But it's really
convenient in the coffee shop
>> good for the
>> coffee the the the transport uh tickets
that we bought in Lisbon.
>> Yeah. And you could see
>> they load the money onto it and each
time you go through the terminal it
deducts an amount from that. That's a
state channel.
>> Yeah. And um
but the thing is with Bitcoin lightning
channels, you can't top them up because
that would
the underlying transaction that you're
overloading that it doesn't know
anything about state channels lightning
network. It it it is just a multi-IG
UTXO.
So it can't be modified onchain. It can
only be essentially well it can be
modified once when you close the
channel. So if you want to top it up you
have to close the channel and open a new
one with different amounts which is
twice as expensive as opening it in the
first place. And given that the Bitcoin
chain is so slow and so expensive,
you don't want to do this often, which
means you don't using lightning channels
dynamically
is not really a thing.
And if it were a thing, it would
overload the Bitcoin network in no time.
And
so it's it's it's not a viable path. Let
me let me put this to you and put this
to you both. Um so in talking to a
Bitcoin maxi uh I will be told that even
if they are willing to possibly concede
that Bitcoin is not in fact um channeled
from God himself on high and is in fact
possibly in need of some adaptation.
Uh they will say but you don't need to
because we have the lightning network.
What are the reality?
What are the realities? I I have to I
have to answer that without laughing,
Craig. So, so do you. Um, so, [laughter]
>> but what if Guam were to tap size?
>> Yeah. So, you know, I I keep a straight
face when I respond to that. Um, and I I
I explain that lightning is essentially
a layer 2. Uh, that you are being put
back into a position of having to trust
the people who are the lightning node
operators. Um,
and and I I I pick at all of these
points and I say in the end up it's
expensive. It's not all that quick. Um,
and it requires quite a bit of
preparation to actually do. Um,
I am nowhere near as technically
competent as you two to describe this.
So, how I I'm a Bitcoin maxi. I tell you
that Bitcoin is perfect, but if it were
to be found in some way needing in need
of adaptation, Lightning Network has
already solved all problems to do with
scalability and now we can use Bitcoin
as a payment solution as it was
originally intended thanks to the grace
of the Lightning network. I
had previously looked into lightning
from the perspective of how the
custodial
architectures that solve the complexity
because it's a dirty hack. It's very
complicated. It's not easy to manage the
complexity. It's explosively complex and
there's a lot of security implications
to that. There are the my previous
investigation to lightning had been
based on the custodial systems that
mitigate that complexity for you by
everybody having basically some
centralized counterparty to all these
channels and so they could do the
balancing for you. Looking at it just
from how does it work,
it's worse. Um the so that's like a
trusted problem. So just to set set
things up a little, I mean you could say
the lightning network was
uh launched in 2018.
Now given the ubiquity of Bitcoin which
was launched in 2009,
you you could say that if Lightning was
everything that its
uh happiest proponents make it out to
be, the question isn't when is it going
to take off, but why hasn't it taken off
already?
>> Yeah. because it was the the system that
was perfectly positioned to take off and
become a global success.
>> Yeah.
>> And and one thing we could one way to
view this discussion is trying to
understand why hasn't it?
>> Sure. Because right now the the total
trans transaction volume on lightning is
somewhere around
>> three transactions per second.
>> Uh yeah, which is which is not
it's not nothing. It's by far the most
successful state channel network in the
world. Um but it should be much more by
now. if there hadn't been consequences,
technical consequences, uh, which end up
being usability consequences that
>> yeah,
>> make people not want to use it as much.
So, so, so just to take off's point and
let's be clear and then I'll pass it
back to you, Greg.
>> Lightning Network has massive amounts of
investment, massive amounts of buy in,
huge drive behind it from the Bitcoin
community to see it work because they
want to have something that allegedly
gives Bitcoin the ability to be a
currency or at least as a store of value
be liquid in its own right as opposed to
illquid and intermediated on somebody
else's ledger. So in every way as you
point out Ol lightning network is like
the it it had everything going for it
and yet
here we are. Yeah. So the so the you
just touched on a point and so did all
and they're two different things. You
said not intermediated and my original
investigation to lightning was looking
at just how intermediate intermediated
is it? Well, it turns out that if you
want to practically use it, it's got to
be pretty darn intermediated.
>> It's extremely intermediated. Yes.
>> But if you don't want to have
intermediation,
you have the problem that UL mentioned,
which is usability. And this is what I
was looking into recently, and wow, it's
like
we're worried that um oh, maybe somebody
will have a hard time understanding they
need to uh copy and paste a Grid's URL
into their wallet. Maybe that'll be hard
for them. That's like our level of
worrying about usability.
Lightning. Wow. You need to set up a
channel with another party
to get routing to work more generally
outside of just you and one other party.
[clears throat] That other party or you
have to have routing set up with
somebody else, which is another channel.
You have to balance liquidity across
these different hops. The hops could be
delayed or deferred. they've got timeout
issues that it's
yeah you can kind of make it work but
it's actually really complicated all the
details of actually how everything is
set up and then if you do run into any
kind of barrier at all and you want to
go back onto the you you want to up as
UL mentioned there is no topping up of
an open channel within lightning you
have to close the channel which is a
commit back to the Bitcoin network so
you got to wait for that to get done and
to continue, you have to open a new
channel. That's a new channel, though.
It's a totally new entity. And so all
the routing stuff that you did to try to
get sorted out in the first place to be
able to do transactions without
intermediation, you have to get that
routing established again. And there's
not really like a good way to do that.
That's the reason that intermediation
popped up in the lightning network is to
manage all that complexity because
normal people are never going to do
this. Like your grandmother can't use
the lightning network
without intermediation.
The second problem with that is if she's
going to use intermediation, why doesn't
she just leave her Bitcoin in an
exchange and do the fake transactions
within exchanges the way that everybody
else just again you get back to the why
not use Postgress question?
>> And the and so it's like it's amazing
that somebody came up with a lightning
network, but the more you look into it,
it's it's like
again you get you ask the question,
what's the difference between a dirty
hack and a and a and a beautiful one?
And this is dirty because it just it the
complexity of it explodes like
immediately the moment you get into like
okay let's use this in my business and
it's whoa okay maybe not
>> I I actually to be fair a lot of good
engineering went into the lightning
network. So it's fascinating. It's not
>> it this is not a a knock on the the
design. Actually our state channels the
if you look at the protocol it even has
uh operations that copied the names of
the bolt protocol. That's the lightning
protocol. It was actually a template
that we used. We just had other things
that we didn't copy like the the onchain
operations that we actually had real
[clears throat] channel state channel.
>> The chain is aware of these.
>> It's not aware of them. to change aware
of it.
>> And we are we've been able to tune the
semantics and and we even then it's been
kind of hard to justify why when would
be the right time to use
uh a state channel like functionality
and it's kind of interesting to go
through what are the actual use cases.
So with lightning on Bitcoin, it's for
any kind of payment that isn't a highv
value settlement settlement between
exchanges or something because
anything you would like to do with
Bitcoin but you can't do on the chain
because it's too slow and expensive has
to be on the lightning network which is
also a reason why it has to be
essentially globally routed which causes
a lot of problems in itself.
So the way we've approached the
[clears throat] whole state channel
thing is to begin with have a chain a
blockchain that's so fast and cheap that
if you just want to
pay for coffee whatever you can do it on
the chain. It's 3-second uh microblock
confirmation, which is not a 100%
guarantee that your transaction won't
possibly be evicted, but but for low
value transactions, it's perfectly fine.
Um,
>> yeah, it's it's a bit like nobody scans
a a $1 note when they put it in the
till, but they will scan a $100 note
when they put it in the till. They'll
make sure that that one is real.
>> Yeah. And what's the throughput on the
chain? Well, on the Gajumaru route, it's
300 transactions per second, which is
like 100 times more than on Bitcoin.
Plus, you have the fast confirmation
time. So, but still there are use cases
where that wouldn't be enough. Like 300
transactions per second, that's
typically Tokyo, the Tokyo subway at
peak time. But
if [clears throat]
assuming you wanted to allocate the
entire capacity of the the chain to
serve the Tokyo subway,
you still have the problem that even 3
seconds response time is too slow.
>> Mhm.
>> So then you'd want immediate response
time. Um now the London subway is about
100 transactions per second. But one
thing you don't necessarily want is if
you have a system that serves the Tokyo
subway, it doesn't also have to serve
the Tokyo subway or the London subway
because
>> yeah, each of them should be their own
state channel because they have very
specific requirements that you can
design that to fulfill. So you could
have a localized state channel system
that serves one market with subsecond
uh finality essentially which is what
you can get with state channels. But
global routing or even multihop routing,
at least from our side, we've chosen to
stay away from that. But at least for
now, but partly because the chain is so
good that you don't you don't
necessarily
>> you don't you don't need the hack even
if it was a beautiful hack. Um
>> yeah. when you can think of one way to
conceive of associate chains in that
context is and Ul and I back in uh you
know a couple years ago I'd asked Ol
about this and we eventually laughed the
idea off because it got so hard so fast
but the idea of multi-party state
channels um
>> and it's like two party state channels
is already like got enough edge cases um
multi-party state channels is is way
harder But associate chains could sort
of be thought of as well that's the
ideal multi-party state channel within
which you can actually define these
insanely fast state channels on top of
that. So you got these layers of
different solutions you can craft at
each level and you can localize them to
a specific problem. So yeah, we don't
have to handle
>> all of the online transactions for a
shop in South America with the Tokyo
subway.
A good intuition for multi-party state
channels is um polygamy
or shared copyrights stuff like that. Uh
>> the problem is with the disputes.
disputes are hard enough with just two
two parties. And uh if you have multiple
parties
uh coming and going, it gets really
terrible. And uh so ask any lawyer about
that. [laughter]
>> Just I'm just conscious of time at this
point. Um so
can one of the two of you give me a
summary of Lightning Network and why it
doesn't work? why why it's a dirty hack
and why it doesn't actually do what
people say it does. Not just that the
the empirical evidence that it doesn't
being that nobody's really using it
despite it having every headwind
possible.
How would you you you bring it home on
lightning network?
>> Well, what's the claim? The claim is
well, Bitcoin is not uh fast enough for
retail transactions, so just use
lightning. And this is a dangerous just.
>> Mhm.
>> And we have this in technology all the
time. Well, just do X and then X is like
insanely hard. Well, just just build a
rocket and you'll go to Mars. Like
[snorts] it's a big just. Um and just
use lightning is one of those just it's
a dangerous just. Uh the pretention is
that
you just have to put your money onto the
lightning network and magically all your
problems are solved. It just transacts
like that quick and everything's fine.
and then you can just put your money out
and put it somewhere else and it's all
it's all solved. No issues.
But the reality is is that there's this
explosively complicated beast down there
that if you want to do it without
intermediation, it's going to be really
freaking hard to do and normal people
aren't going to do that. So that's just
a that's just a non-starter already the
complexity of it.
>> So So to to pause you there, what are
normal people doing? Because this is
where I say that lightning network is
actually a layer two. It's a layer two
made up of lots of agg of of of nodes,
but it the the the intermediated version
is that you trust all those nodes
because they have stakes.
>> Uh which means we're back to trusting
people who we have no good reason.
>> Yeah. And so just use the bank. Like
it's it's kind of hard to make the
argument for even being involved in
because of the overhead, because of the
complexity. And then you're
reintroducing the very thing that you
were trying to get away from, which is a
trustful system without oversight. And
that's the without oversight is the big
crunching part right there. Um,
>> yeah. And
>> if you have these counterparties
regulated might be different.
>> Yeah. So many of the problems of
lightning boil down to the fact that
they're actually implemented on top of
bitcoin. And uh so the thing about if
you have a routing node, rebalancing
liquidity is really hard because you
can't rebalance liquidity
unless you close and and create new
channels which are onchain operations.
So if you get a lot of traffic and a lot
of dynamic behavior on lightning, it's
going to swamp the the underlying chain
immediately. So you can't really do
that. So it becomes really static or how
do you manage the liquidity statically?
Well, you have to overprovision which
>> it's a glass cannon problem.
>> Yeah.
>> If you use it, you won't have it
anymore.
>> Okay. So
parking lightning network there for the
time being. Um where do we see
runes ordinals? How how are they playing
into this?
Occasionally things pop up in crypto
that boggle the mind and this is one of
those. Um
so the basic idea is that you would
in in with ordinals that you would in
pick one Satoshi and like in you know
stamp it with some data that now makes
it identifiable. It's no longer funible.
So, you've made an NFT out of a single
Satoshi.
>> To what end?
>> Giant question marks there. Uh, that
don't really have good answers.
>> It basically it kind of feels like,
well, look, we can do NFTs, too. Um,
>> yeah.
>> Now,
so say you would want to use that to
store an image on Bitcoin. So the
wow
>> the limit is essentially you could store
up to like 3.9 megabytes
uh as a Satoshi inscription as an
ordinal
with today's prices the cost of that I
mean it would have to compete with what
the typical total fees are for a block
which is over $100,000.
So it would be a pretty expensive uh
pick and also Bitcoin doesn't support
garbage collection or data lifetime.
>> So ju just to to come back to the point
you're making here you see the argument
made about runes is that runes
effectively allow bitcoin to become a uh
a network that can bring a payload of
data through. It's not just NFTTS in the
stupid sense, you know, the the the
board a morons.
Um it it the idea might be that there
would be an actual nonfgeible token
capacity to this that would be
descriptive of let's say a chemical
change in a process that tells you that
something has actually happened and that
this information could be recorded as a
nonfgeible token onto the Bitcoin
network which was I can I I mean I I
listening to that in a in a a
presentation I did have to suppress my
need to enough but um a lot actually
because it was really the the sincerity
of which they said these things was
hysterical
but and it obviously takes some really
good acting skills to do that. I mean I
thought I could act but these guys are
on a different plane. Um
and what they were basically arguing is
this is how we make Bitcoin relevant to
enterprise
not just as money because that's clearly
failed but rather as a means of having
total trust in the truth of
a state a thing in in the way that NFTts
might be used correctly. their
nonfgeible
stamp that something has occurred that
the shipment has left the building for
example.
>> So one of the um phrases that people
often want to use and almost everyone
uses it uh wrongly is begging the
question. This is actually begging the
question that the conclusion is that we
want to use Bitcoin.
So, how can we then reverse engineer all
kinds of things
onto Bitcoin as well to make it
relevant? Um, and of course
you could potentially do it, but we're
talking about a different Bitcoin than
the one we're seeing because if you if
people would take
runes or ordinals seriously and actually
start using them,
they would flood the network in no time.
Again, with the throughput and cost of
the underlying chain,
it's not a viable business case. uh
because you run into a brick wall as
soon as people start picking it up and
actually using it at any level of scale.
So then we're talking about something
else. We have to be talking about
Bitcoin SV then which tweaks Bitcoin by
just simply increasing the block size
so that you can get really
high total throughput.
But then if you use monster machines,
which essentially drives a lot of
centralization, you have a bunch of
monster machines that are doing all the
the block production connected with
gigabit or 10 gigabit uh network links
and
driving up disk space requirements.
>> What is it? Seven terabytes.
>> Yeah. and increasing at a at an amazing
rate.
>> This is every time
>> actually doing much in terms of
>> I don't know what the problem is. There
is an infinite ability to create data
libraries. Did you not know that?
[clears throat]
>> So, [laughter]
>> sorry. And it's it's interesting the u I
mean one way to look at Bitcoin as well
there is an interesting graph uh on this
blockchain.com which is cost per
transaction.
If you include the mining rewards and
the fees,
the
cost per transaction
right now is around 110
or it's more than $100
per transaction.
um which is uh essentially a function of
the very high price of Bitcoin and the
very low throughput
and
you should always be suspicious of
systems that have a huge amount of total
cost. Essentially, you're subsidizing
the cost of
of the transa like the fee you pay for
the transaction is just a fraction of
the total cost of of processing it. And
you could say that it's unfair to to
roll in the cost of mining rewards
because that's the act actually the cost
of printing money for the future. But on
the other hand, there's no point in
printing money for the future if you
don't have a business case that drives a
need for it.
So if you don't have if you don't have
any real commercial traffic, then
then essentially you're borrowing from
your children to pay for the to pay for
this whole thing. And that that's where
we get to the the problem of like global
the global throughput of Bitcoin where
Bitcoin has now been bunkered the same
way gold gets put into a vault. It's all
like almost nobody does transactions on
chain in practice.
They just have it in exchanges and then
within the exchange ledgers they
>> unregulated exchanges I should add.
Right. And see, this is the and this
gets back to that problem where they're
sort of trying like the exchanges have
evolved to this point where
they've they're not really functioning
as exchanges where there's a buyer and a
seller that are being matched. They're
not really market making in that sense
and they're also not um they're not a
multilateral trading facility because
there aren't multiple biders in the
system, multiple buyers in the system.
They're a market maker. they have a
partial opening of that book to other
people within the system. But basically,
a lot of that book is not on the screen.
In a multilateral trading facility, it's
on the screen. Now, um, pulling to that,
it's not a multilateral trading
facility, which which is what an
exchange should be. They're called
exchanges because they named themselves
exchanges. It would be like me calling
myself Bank of Greg. Uh, am I a bank?
No. Would you like to believe me? Maybe
if you're a complete fool. Um
the the issue is and you touched on it
earlier is without oversight. It's not
that we're fanboys of regulation because
very often regulation is actually really
about perpetuating the corporatist model
in the first place. What we're fans of
is oversight because if you're putting
somebody in a position of trust there
should be oversight. And we don't see
this anywhere in any of these [snorts]
systems. I mean for example circle have
made a big song and dance about the fact
that they are making themselves open for
attestation by an accounting firm but
yet not one of the major accounting
firms actually wants to give them this
attestation because that is not an
audit. [snorts] Um [laughter]
>> that's like hey what's the new what's
the new amazing feature? We're going to
let somebody kind of look at stuff
maybe.
>> Yeah. Uh, and then you know, you look,
>> imagine a bank saying that.
>> There's a guy on Twitter called Bit for
Next, and you should look at everything
he writes because or she writes, I have
no idea if it's a he or she, um, by the
aggression that they use in some of
their language. I'm pretty sure it's a
he. Um, and he's taken down Tether so
many different ways around, it's
hilarious. And if you if you see the
stuff that he's he's saying about it, I
it's mindboggling how anybody thinks
that this entire system can work like
this. I mean, we touched on this back in
0. We're talking about stable coins and
we said, well, you know, the irony is
they're neither a coin, they're neither
they're not stable and they're not a
coin. um they are a trust me we have
this money in reserve and if you decide
that you actually want to take out the
real thing we can give it to you it's
it's a it's extremely pile of nonsense
but um
coming back to ordinals and runes it's
very much a case and Ol nailed this when
he said that what's happened here is
that they've started with an with an end
and they've then tried to to beg the
question to create the
Right.
The answer is going to be Bitcoin. So,
um
it's it's warped Jeopardy.
>> Yeah. So, runes and ordinals um are
cited as being ways that show that
Bitcoin is useful in a
commercial/economic context. So let
let's let's come back a second and
define first off what is a rune, what is
an ordinal, and then talk about why
they're dirty hacks and why they fail.
>> So runes are essentially fungeable
tokens.
>> [clears throat]
>> So you can create your own token by
uh abusing the Bitcoin UTXO
uh unspent transaction output uh model.
And um
if you look at I mean normally on say
Ethereum and on Gajumanu you would use
smart contracts to represent
a token. Um which means if you want to
you can take a template contract for a
smart token. You can tweak it to to your
own particular needs. You can make it
much more flexible. you can control many
more things than you could basically
with uh with runes as far as I
understand it because it again it's
limited by the fact that Bitcoin doesn't
really know what it what you're doing to
it. Um
you have to stay within the very narrow
confines of what that core
uh construct actually allows.
And uh so that makes it a limited
version of functional or fungeible
tokens that you can't really you can't
go in many places with it. You can't
really evolve it in many ways. And also
anything you try to do with it, it's
going to have to be on the blockchain,
which again is Bitcoin, which is slow
and expensive. And
again, if it's going to take off, it's
going to kill the chain more or less.
So, and kill your business case because
fees are going to be through the roof
and it's not going to be usable in
practice. So [clears throat] given that
there are already better uh fungeible
token solutions out there actually
um a lot of especially in the Ethereum
world that have worked pretty well in
practice
again with their own sets of problems. I
what are we trying to do here? Are we
trying to show that we can actually
do a graphical interface in a VT 100 uh
text terminal? It's possible,
but why would you want to do it that
way? There are
>> because number go up. I don't know how
you didn't get that memo. Number go up.
Number go up equals Lambo.
>> Yeah, because Bitcoin [clears throat] is
the one currency.
But if
if we see the Bitcoin community
basically being pretty
uh strongly lodged in the high value
settlement
business and and essentially speculating
on on the market rate.
Um,
why do we want to how what are the
chances that we're going to be able to
push the Bitcoin community and the
Bitcoin implementation in
in a direction where this business case
can even take off given that essentially
we have to redesign the entire network
before we can get it to take off? I I
think it it's really just a case of
trying to um create new reasons for
people to to not look at the inherent
flaws and instead look at the
possibility that if we all just clicked
our ruby heels together three times, we
may in fact end up back in Kansas. Um,
>> so I mean there could be marginal use
cases where it's good that you can
actually sort of do these things on
Bitcoin as well.
I'm just at a loss for what they might
be
>> because of the because of that problem
where like
>> if you use it even to a modest degree
you break the system
>> and in a different in many different
numbers of ways but most of it plays out
in transaction fee contention.
>> Uh and we still don't solve the storage
problem. There's just this list of
problems that are like the storage
problem, right? Like you can't store
everything forever, ever, ever. But
that's what the
>> Well, that's what BFB's position is, is
that whoever wants to run nodes is going
to have to spend millions of dollars
buying extraordinarily high-end
computers and server farms to in to be
able to actually operate the data at the
necessary throughputs and speed. It's
ridiculous. Um but unfortunately
there's a sort of a self-fulfilling
aspect to some of the people involved in
these things where they think well yes
we should do this because we're special.
Um you know going back to lightning
momentarily the interesting thing I find
about that is that the people who are
telling you well I can just do this this
and this and you know as per you said
just um they're they're people who are
phenomenally technically capable who've
been doing this for many many years and
yes for them it's it's a little bit like
um Pete Samprass can can serve an
incredible top spinning um serve you
know yes of course he can because he's
brilliant. He's one of the greatest
tennis players ever. But the average
person cannot do that with a ball. Full
stop. And if they can, it's fluke. Um,
so you know, these are the these are the
reality of these impediments. So, uh,
coming away from runes and going to
ordinals.
>> It's like explain pro golf. Oh, well,
they just hit a ball into a hole.
>> Yep. Uh,
>> oh, it's just so easy. Why doesn't
everyone do that?
>> Yeah. It's like uh the one time that I
ever got I was ever allowed to take a
conversion in rugby, it was because it
was a hurricane of a a day, you know,
massive gusting winds, high winds when
it wasn't gusting. Um it was at the very
edge of the field where I'd scored and I
just said to the fly half, "There's no
way you're going to hit that, is there?"
He said, "No." I said, "Would you let me
have a go?" And I actually nailed it. I
I actually nailed it. Right. And people
were laughing saying, "We'll have to get
you to take the kicks." And I said, "No,
that was that was literally a lottery
win." Um, you know, I I I judged that it
would I would kick there and it might go
there. Um, and by pure luck, it got
there. I couldn't do that. If you if you
if you gave me the exact same
circumstances a million times, I would
probably only have hit it that one time.
[laughter] This is the reality.
>> That's not what I'm going to tell
everyone at dinner tonight.
No, it wasn't. [laughter]
>> I nailed it. I knew I had that.
>> But, you know, the thing of it is I I I
know that to be a top level kicker,
these guys are spending three or four
hours a day to get to an 85% hit rate.
That's that's the real skill is
repetition. Um but look coming back from
that to to ordinals
uh how do ordinals differ from runes for
simple as a simple explanation. So
ordinals would be nonfgeable tokens.
Then they're essentially [clears throat]
a pointer. I mean you you can you can
abuse the the inscriptions that
basically you can annotate a single
Satoshi and treat it as
some data object on.
>> And just for the audience, what is a
Satoshi? Satoshi is the smallest uh
denomination of Bitcoin. It's like
>> the same as a as a in 100 millionth I
think.
>> Yeah. So it's [clears throat]
interesting. Um 10 Satoshi's are about
one cent one
US cent right now. So
>> the another problem that the price of
Bitcoin has been driven up so high that
you don't really have that much
resolution left. Uh
>> yeah, it's about to get really blocky if
it keeps going.
>> But
so yeah, it's I mean so we've had
discussions
around NFTTS before. is like the trivial
version of an
>> I still haven't published those videos
about NFTs because they're not very
nice.
>> [laughter]
>> So, a trivial version of an NFT is you
take a picture of your socks or
something. You put it up on a an
auction. Someone decides to pay
a million bucks for the right to have a
little blockchain object that has a
picture of your socks and they have
somehow ownership of that even though
it's not enforcable.
There are a lot of things that you would
>> all of these inconveniences. Skip over
them, please. [laughter]
>> Well,
well, that's what you pretty much have
to do if you want to do this on the
Bitcoin chain, right? because
um
well
you c you can of course overload a lot
of
information into this payload,
but Bitcoin is still not going to know
anything about what it means. So
>> there is this religion within the
Bitcoin community that as long as you
can store a hash on the Bitcoin chain,
it can basically represent every
anything. So you can have your hugely
complex system which is essentially what
like the Bitcoin OS rollups or more or
less boil down to like you store a few
hashes on the chain or signatures
and that represents something.
is
>> this was the downfall of chains too
>> that's going on on the side not actually
on the chain. Um and the the contention
is that as long as you can do that you
can do anything you want and you don't
need any other system.
Now
I know that in typical bank transactions
I can store a message. I don't know if
it's long enough to store a crypto hash.
But hey, maybe we can get the banks to
increase that message size a little bit
so that we can we can exchange crypto
hashes in normal bank transactions. And
that would be roughly
well a similar
you can apply the same type of thinking
there that
you're using a storage and transfer
medium that is not in
>> I'm just laughing because I'm I'm
imagining a website where we're going to
look up who owns what car amongst us and
the way that it works is that it opens
up like a websocket to a bank that's
totally unrelated to us and it's looking
up transaction messages that are stored
that we just have to know how to get to
the numbers of to to pull them out and
then we're like that's proof see that's
my car totally
>> like that's kind of a silly idea
>> I I I have to say I did think Ol was
being very generous when he used the um
the verb thinking in his discussion of
all of this because it it's hard to
think how somebody was thinking when
>> well I mean a hallucination's a thought
[clears throat]
>> it is in a in a in a nonfunctional
>> and most thoughts are dumb and the other
half of your brain filters them out and
like makes sure that the dumb ones don't
come up too much except for the little
voice that you and I we just like keep
shut up most of the time most of the
time [laughter]
>> but I mean going back to that uh Q do
analogy if you can just generate enough
interest and enough demand then maybe
you can if you're a committed
Bitcoin engineer and innovator you can
get enough
support for actually being able to
evolve the chain into something that you
wish it would be.
>> It's
it doesn't explain why the rest of us
should should jump onto this when there
are actually viable alternatives.
>> Well, hold on before we get to viable
alternatives because I think you nailed
it earlier when you said what's really
happened here is they've decided the
answer is Bitcoin. it must be Bitcoin
because you know how are we going to
continue to create these narratives? How
are we going to continue take this
create this idea that it is more than it
actually was? That it's not just a proof
of concept and it's not locked in time
to be a proof of concept. That's really
what's happening. That's what's driving
all of this. the latest one and the one
that I I have to say I I thought I was
maturing incredibly well because what
happened was I went to an event where
the Bitcoin OS founder was bouncing
around the room in a hoodie like this
with a baseball cap on because obviously
his mother never told him told him to
take his hat off indoors. Uh all the
things that irritate me before somebody
even opens their mouth were occurring
here. Um
and then he proceeded to tell the story
about how he was sitting in MIT
researching neural networks when he came
across the first iteration of the
Bitcoin white paper and it was actually
to do with gambling
um and not about being uh what it
became. Um but he saw within it the
kernels of truth that turned it into the
thing that became the north star for the
entirety of his life. And his life story
from that point on had been about diving
further and further into this incredible
technology. And then he went on to
explain that Bitcoin OS was how we were
going to make Bitcoin really work. And
it was as if everything that he said in
the first 15 minutes of his bouncing
around the stage telling us all about
his first exposure to Bitcoin and how it
changed his life. It became his north
star. became Jesus Christ, God, and the
the Holy Spirit all in the one. You
know, Father, Ghost, and the Holy Spirit
was now Bitcoin for him. And yet his
proposal was to effectively say, and I
built a layer, too. That's awesome. And
we got a really cool name for it. So,
you know, 100% we're cool, rock and
roll. Let's make Bitcoin work together.
Now, my maturity was that for once I
didn't take him apart on stage and
instead I just walked out. I was like,
"Okay, I'm kind of tired of being the
only person in the room who sees this
for the felicious [__] that it is,
and I'm tired of being the one person
who seems to be the only person in the
room that will point this out. So, I'm
just going to give up and walk out."
>> Did he Did he like speak with that, you
know, like the the booming megaurch
voice? Because it sounds like that kind
of story. The angel of the Lord told me
to regard my life. He was he was far too
much of a weedy uh weasel to make that
kind of noise. The kind of people you're
referring to, a big big baritone voiced
um the preachers.
>> This was a whiny irritating guy with a
baseball cap and uh
>> and a uh hoodie who was sort of
>> But the buildup is similar.
to stay true to the
>> you you can stay true to the uh original
ideas and still replace
uh components that are no longer
sufficient uh rather than trying to use
them. Uh, I just we uh just actually
my son got
uh his 4070
uh TI super graphics card the other day
because he's been playing Path of Exile.
He's an excellent gamer and his favorite
super ultimate combo would bring his old
1080 Ti to its knees basically down to
two frames per second or something. So
anytime he used it, he would die because
essentially his graphics card would
almost lock up. Uh it's amazing how good
the TI 1080 Ti has been so far. But here
he was able to completely uh overload
it. So with his new graphics card, it's
actually 25 frames per second when he's
doing his super combo. And uh that
actually makes it usable. So you know,
some ideas can actually become amazing
if you use an underlying architecture
and implementation that supports them.
and the um
>> novel
>> as a
kind of
metaphor.
Um you can use ordinals, but you're only
going to get three frames per second
>> across the whole world. That's everybody
in the world. That's all you can do.
>> Yeah.
>> No, this is like that's just a
non-starter.
>> I [clears throat] mean, like it should
be obvious that that's a silly idea. One
nice thing about Bitcoin OS is that they
have essentially built a rollup
framework
that
at least on paper in their documentation
supports any virtual machine.
Um, for now it's uh it's the EVM, but
presumably it could be something else.
they mention Salena, Rust, smart
contracts. So they virtualized the
virtual machine so that they can produce
uh zero knowledge proof so that they can
store some hashes on Bitcoin.
Um now
that's there is some really cool
engineering that has gone into that and
um
it's it's not really uh fully
operational yet. They're pushing some
next generation
features in terms of zero knowledge
proofs and everything. Per I would
prefer to run my smart contracts
natively on chain if the chain actually
supports it.
>> Why would you want to do something so
silly as that?
>> Yeah. Oh, you're you're you're being
really nice, but all I'm all I keep
thinking of is like there was a lot of
nice expensive engineering that went
into the Juicerero
and that was a piece of trash. That was
a completely stupid idea.
>> It probably wouldn't be hard to retarget
the Bitcoin OS to instead of using
Bitcoin uh using it on Gajumaru for
example, it would be easy to retarget it
because that part is
>> that part's very disconnected. Yeah. you
just don't need it necessarily. But but
hey, you could then run your smart
contracts and checkpoint them uh roll
them up to the Gajumano chain or any
other chain that has much better
characteristics than Bitcoin. We have I
think we have enough Juicero solutions
in the Bitcoin space though where like
you can do
>> what's
Juicero is a
it was a um
I know this is going to sound like I'm
making something up or telling you like
a story a plot line from South Park but
this actually happened for real. So,
somebody had this idea that they were
going to sell organic juice and they
were going to sell a juicer machine that
would like get the juice out of the
package. I
I know getting juice out of packages is
like not a big technical problem that
most people have, but this was the way
that they like evolved this product. So,
you buy a Juicerero machine
that's pretty expensive and then you
have to buy Juicerero juice bags. The
juice comes in a bag and then you have
to God there's there's instruction
videos from when they publish this
product that is hilarious. You open the
juicer thing. It sits on your counter.
It's huge. It sits on your counter. You
open the front. You put the juice bag in
there and there's like little scanner
things and like a camera and all the
stuff on the inside of this. You put the
juice bag in there. close the machine
and you push like juice it and juice
comes out of the bottom and hopefully
you put a cup there. Um,
and the whole thing was that you have to
buy their juice bags or else. And the
way they enforce this is all that
scanning stuff inside there's like
taking a there's a QR code on it.
There's like a bar thing. There's all
this color stuff. um they're they're
scanning to make sure that you're
actually using one of their juice bags
and not anything else or else it won't
work. And the juicing machine costs a
ton of money and if your internet access
goes down, it can't check with the
server whether that was one of their
juice bags. So, it won't work. If it's
like one day out of date, it won't juice
it for your safety or whatever. And the
whole time you could just like grab the
juice bag and just like do this and it
would just squeeze the juice out anyway.
you didn't need the machine and you
don't need to buy their juice anyway
because lots of people sell juice. So
the whole thing was like and this was
like tens of millions of dollars dumped
into this product. Lots of fine
engineering, lots of problems were
solved to produce this dumb machine and
it was just dumb. Like you could just
like there's trees outside. Go get a
pair. But no, we're gonna have I'm gonna
have a kitchen appliance that if my
internet connection goes down, it won't
even work to buy overpriced juice stuff
that I have to do a certain way that
only they allow me to do it this one
certain way. And if I don't, then I
can't drink juice. It's just insane. And
so, of course, the thing failed. Um, but
it somehow
>> Well, it's funny you say that cuz as
you're describing it, I hear Bitcoin
being described and it hasn't failed
mainly because because of it quality
>> that there's this there's a there's time
scale thing here in in motion and
Juicero while it was in development.
They had the best hype people. They were
all over the California scene telling
everybody in San Francisco, you know, up
and down all the all the expensive
streets in LA and in Los an in um San
Francisco that um this is going to be
the next big thing. It's juice. You like
juice. You're you're a vegan. This is
just for you. This hey, we got the kale
juice and the whatever. um all the cool
stuff to say in California at that time
got them millions and millions and
millions of dollars of money just dumped
on just showered on opened up to spigots
and they worked hard to produce a
useless product but it was all this hype
spin up for something that ultimately
was useless so if we look at the kind of
metaphor there you know I don't know
there's a little bit of a mismatch here
because the underlying idea of Bitcoin
is good It's it pro it's a proof of
concept that proves something that is
genuinely a good idea. Um but the sort
of rise and perhaps eventual fall of
this is we're we're on a longer timeline
but it's all driven by hype and things
like ordinals are just they're hype.
They're not really useful. But that the
utility of them is that you can still
make the number go up. And
>> it's just sort of like
>> I mean there is a way to steel man it.
Um, I guess uh if you accept the premise
that
Bitcoin is really the only ubiquitous
blockchain currency.
>> Mhm.
>> And one [clears throat] problem with all
the competing uh in many ways superior
technically superior blockchains is that
they failed to field a successful
competitor to the currency Bitcoin. M
[clears throat]
>> that's that's a good criticism though in
the sense that most of them have
currencies that do not pass
>> the uncorruptibility test
>> and of course convers
but this is one thing that we've been
discussing a lot and uh and if you want
to discuss it long enough you get to the
point of okay why aren't those other
currencies
successful in competing it's like well
because they
they didn't solve the problem of
uh attracting actual commercial use
cases to
>> their [clears throat] chains. So, it was
just another gambling currency and then
you might as well go with Bitcoin
because it it really has a
>> I think there's an element of dis of
market despair as well. Just we're
living through the everything is fake
economy. You know, airlines try to
become banks. They make themselves
indispensable, you know, strategic
services so that when they do fail,
they'll get bailed out, which means they
can make risky investments into things
that have nothing to do with airlines.
They only do air operations to maintain
the label of airline. that kind of weird
stuff is going on to such a huge degree
that
if you're just, you know, Joe Truck
driver
and you're looking at your costs
accelerating
and your revenues declining or
flatlining,
well, eventually they're just going to
they're they're telling me that they're
just going to replace my job anyway. I'm
redundant. I'm a useless eater. Um, and
they said that very directly. Uh, that's
the media message. and everything I do
is a horrible sin because driving a
truck is bad because green whatever. Um
it's all these disparaging messages and
there's a lot of despair in the system
right now. Uh and I think that we're
looking at sort of a South Sea bubble
where the South Sea bubble was 1711
somebody started a South Sea company. Uh
and they said, "Hey, foreign trade is
going to be the big thing. This is the
age of sale. Trade is it. That's the
that's the next big thing. Get in
early." That's not wrong. And history
proves that that was the big thing to
get into in the 1700s. However, this
ignited it went viral for the day and
everybody in London got into this crazy
speculation bubble and there were
shysters that started realizing, hey, I
can do something sneaky here. The big
path, the quick path to money is not to
do a trading company. is to say I'm
going to found a trading company because
then people buy my shares and I get the
money and then I can just you know
disappear and go to Germany or
something. Um well protogerermany it's
time that so this that kind of
sneakiness there's a real thing here
that Bitcoin proved you can do and then
Ethereum proved you can innovate on top
of that. Okay, cool. There's something
real here. But we're in sort of a South
Sea bubble right now where we've got a
real premise, but all the, you know, all
the rats have just showed up and they're
selling each other, they're selling each
other wax calling it cheese right now.
And this problem is just accelerating
until we're going to hit we're going to
hit an eventual crash somewhere. What's
happening on the despair side that I
mentioned though that did not happen in
London in the 1700s was
instead of this just being a series of
Ponzi schemes remember you know Ponzi
like the original Ponzi that the scheme
is named after after or Bernie Maidoff
they claimed that they had like amazing
analysts that were doing amazing work
and were getting incredible returns and
I'm a super genius people believed that
there was something really going on
there the South Sea affair people really
believed that there was a proposition of
return based on trade over time.
In this case, when you look at like
blatant Ponzi schemes, you know, blah
blah token, Fartcoin, perfect example,
when you look at Fartcoin,
>> which Yeah. And it so and you get with
Trump, Trumpcoin has one special feature
to it, which is the same feature that
Doge had going for it, which was that as
a memecoin, people getting into and
actually this extends to the whole space
now. People are not expecting these to
be anything other than posies at this
point. And they're saying everything is
fake in the economy. Everybody hates me.
Everything I do is immoral according to
them. Screw it. I'm just going to
gamble. And they're going in with their
eyes open. A lot of people are getting
into crypto saying the right words, but
what they're doing is they're getting
into the casino and they know it's a
casino. They they're fully aware that
this is all just Ponzi trash. It's going
to fall apart and they're they're
saying, "Well, everything's going to
fall apart anyway, so I may as well take
a risk."
>> [clears throat]
>> And uh that's sad. That's really sad.
>> I I think there's a lot of that going on
in this stuff and there's something that
I'd like to explore in a great deal more
detail with you guys. Um but coming back
to the point that Ulf is making and and
you've made uh there's only one currency
as it's seen within the space. Uh,
Dogecoin is also mined, but it was
literally done as a joke and that's all
it was. And it it was very popular joke
for a while, but that's everything that
it was. It's now a 30, sorry, it's a
it's a $2 billion joke at this stage.
Sorry, market cap. Forgive me wrong.
>> It's a 37.6
billion joke at this stage. And
these things are not jokes because
they're actually playing at people's
loss of hope. Exactly as you point out,
people are becoming more and more aware
that we are in a fallacy of everything
world. Um
all of the other currencies XRP, Solana,
Soul, BNB, Cardano, all of them, they're
all proof of stake. They're all created
by clicking one's heels together three
times and saying, "I will create a
cryptocurrency. I will create a
cryptocurrency." And paboom. Um, and
there's there's no substance to it that
because there's no business underlying
it. There's none of these things that
that we could anchor value to. Uh, and
this is on top of that all of them
involve governance. The moment that you
have governance, the moment that you
have control, you do not have a
resource. You have an infrastructure.
and that infrastructure is controlled.
It's debasable. It's everything that it
shouldn't be if it's going to be a
functional currency. But just to to
finish this conversation out
on this point, um
we've answered the kind of what was
going to be my last question. Why do
people why do people keep pretending
that these solutions are actually
solutions and not simply bad patches to
a fatally flawed starting point? The
answer is, as we've identified through
the conversation, because people want
the number to go up on Bitcoin, it's the
only thing that's actually shown that it
can be a currency. Tron, sorry, not
Tron. Dogecoin cannot be a currency, if
only because it was intended to be a
joke in the first place. It suffers from
many of Bitcoin's failings and therefore
it's not really going to lend itself to
the change that would need to be to turn
Doge into something other than the joke
and the and actually it's
the joke is on people. It's not on the
founders because they made a ton of
money out of it.
It's not on Elon Musk because he made a
ton of money out of this.
The joke is on all the poor people who
thought that
>> who didn't take it as a joke.
>> Correct. who who began to see some
>> um so
>> linking back to the begging the question
thing why why is there so much energy
put into trying to prove that Bitcoin is
relevant as a technology platform now
you could argue that the main feature of
Bitcoin is that the people who jumped on
to I heard about it first time in 2009 I
believe someone suggested I should start
mining Bitcoin.
[clears throat]
Would if I had, but um I was busy at the
time. But those who did, those who were
dominant miners in the first
um in the early days
are super rich now,
at least to the extent that they can
actually convert the Bitcoin to to fiat.
>> That's a whole different question. and
um
I think you're treading into territory
that we'd like to explore at great deal
more length on which is is Bitcoin even
a store of value. Um the point that
we'll we'll finish on with here is
that it was it was the the approach was
to say the answer is Bitcoin and that's
why we have all these dirty hacks. The
dirty hacks are a result of of all of
the moving parts within how Bitcoin has
been constructed, what's happened around
it. And what we end up seeing is Bitcoin
OS, which is
just to finish the point on Bitcoin OS,
how would you describe Bitcoin OS? We
didn't actually do a conclusion to that.
>> It's basically a layer two. Um,
>> but h how exactly?
So
for example you can run the idea is you
can run say uh solidity contracts um and
then you can package the result
in as a zero knowledge proof and commit
that to Bitcoin. This is how the layer 2
chains essentially operate on Ethereum.
And um so Bitcoin OS does roughly the
same thing
but with Bitcoin.
Um now
and of course suffers from the problem
that
Bitcoin is slow and expensive and um
so
from a technological point of view well
yeah kind of cool project was really fun
to work on but um what does it
what does it bring to the table?
>> Mhm. Unless the point is it really has
to be Bitcoin.
>> That's the origin of most hacks by the
way. Just like the getting stuff done in
a context that's awkward and you have to
like you know we don't have any other
way to possibly deploy code in that
context. What can we possibly do? Well,
we could put an interpreter on the
client side and we could pretend that a
document's program sort of
>> like and that's how the web was born.
But that's because the answer was
already going to be HTTP because
everyone else had kind of forgotten
socket programming. Um, no. So
>> if you would compare for example running
Solidity contracts in Bitcoin OS and
checkpointing onto Bitcoin
>> compared to running it in an Ethereum
layer 2. Well, Ethereum could actually
run those Solidity contracts. You could
run them onchain. It's just too
expensive.
>> So people don't do that. So then they
offload it and run it on a layer 2 chain
which is kind of centralized
um and then they can checkpoint it onto
the uh the Ethereum chain. Now the
Ethereum chain is more capable than
actually validating the
zero knowledge proofs. You could
actually do that in a solidity contract
on chain. Now, with Bitcoin OS, Bitcoin
can't really validate the the proof. It
can only store the hashes of the of the
proof.
>> That's actually a question I've got
about that. Where is the state
transition stored? Where do you look
that up for Bitcoin OS? Is that
universal or is it per?
>> They have added a form of a vault and I
guess it it is also a version of
sort of
um more or less being able to manage
fungeible tokens to support crosschain
uh transfers using Bitcoin as a transfer
medium. Um and that can also be used by
Bitcoin OS so that you can you can also
sort of
manage value transfers in these rollups
um not just contract call results but
you have to verify everything offchain
because Bitcoin can't really verify any
of it. it can just store the hashes and
in one particular religion this is
sufficient.
>> Um
I
I fail to see
what it brings to the table other than
hey you can do this with Bitcoin too.
It's going to be slower. It's going to
be more expensive. it's going to be uh
still suffer from the the problem that
all the problems that Bitcoin has.
But but hey, it's Bitcoin. So
>> I I think that kind of nails the whole
point. So with that, gentlemen, thank
you very much indeed for your time.
Thank you everybody who joined us for
this uh discussion. We'd love to get
your questions. Please put them into the
channels that we put the the statement
out on. And thank you very much indeed
for watching.